[Music]
foreign
canceled for two years in a row the
world's largest beer festival is back
welcome to the covid-19 special
everyone here at Munich's Oktoberfest
knows they could easily get infected
with the Coronavirus you can't always
tell if someone's got it
and that's the focus of our show this
week what percentage of covid-19 cases
are asymptomatic
but first let's hear Moses mashiri's
covered story
[Music]
it was scary and the fact that I had to
wait from 7 pm to 3 AM
then at the corridor Norwich oxygen mask
you see someone who has died for you to
get a space you're going to the same bed
I was scared I thought I will not make
it I'm Moses machiri I live in Nairobi I
had coffee 19. it was June in 2020 when
I realized I was not feeling well I
thought it was just a normal flu I had
difficulties in breathing I could not
eat my wife suggested to go to Avenue
hospital and they did the kovid test
after the test also did not get a bed
unfortunately that's when someone died I
was around there they were moved out of
the hdu and I got a space I was put on
an isolation room I realized it's
covered when the nurse in charge had to
wear the suit actually before kovid I
had taken 20 years without stepping to
hospital that was my first time to
actually to be admitted and treated of
serious I didn't have any other
complication
but after the treatment I realized I
became allergic to cold
cold and cold stuffs from there once I
was discharged I was told to isolate for
10 days everything that I'm using it's
only me so you could only communicate
through the phone
everyone was scared at home but thank
God no one was infected my wife had to
stop working to take care of me because
I was not able to eat it took like five
weeks I was declared coffee free but
still I was healing we were told you can
get reinfected but I believe
I will not anytime in I'm in public I
always do my mask
I have to sanitize those vaccinated
the first and the second vaccination I
had an insurance cover but when I was
discharged they said they will not cover
so it was a shock for me
to have a huge bill I had to take a loan
I'm here to recover from the financials
I went through in Kenya the government
has put in places where you have to do
masks in public places and this
sanitization honestly
they're helping but I don't think they
are enough because
they're not followed
strictly especially with those the
people who are
who never got the covered they don't
know the way to feed they assume they're
not followed to the letter
[Music]
time now for some covid-19 studies that
have been hitting the headlines
today I want to look at another one of
those studies where you read the title
and go what
impaired ketogenesis ties metabolism to
T Cell dysfunction in covet 19.
just stick with me for a second though
because the researchers at the
University of Bonn where the work took
place also published in easy to
understand article on what it's all
about it's titled covid-19 new energy
for flagging immune cells immune cells
do not receive sufficient suitable
energy carriers in infected individuals
much better right the researchers hope
their results can help solve one of the
many Mysteries surrounding covet 19. why
do some people get much sicker than
others
but first things first
when you catch other books like the flu
it changes your metabolism
because when you get sick you often lose
your appetite and if you don't eat
enough your body starts burning its fat
Reserves
that process produces molecules called
Ketone bodies which are rich in energy
they fill the Gap left when
carbohydrates run out one Ketone body is
called beta hydroxybutyrate or BHB for
short
BHB acts as an alternative carbon source
and can compensate for amino acid
deficiencies promoting T-cell survival
in humans and mice
that weed from one of the study's
authors hints at another purpose Ketone
bodies have they play an extremely
important role in immune system function
both T helper cells and T killer cells
need the energy-rich molecules to
perform the key tasks
and there lies the wrap the researchers
found that people with moderate to
severe cases of covid-19 didn't seem to
be pumping up Ketone production
in them the vital immune system cells
might be starved of energy and less able
to attack the virus effectively
so maybe that's at least part of the
reason they develop a more serious case
of the disease the good news is that
this kind of immune deficit can
potentially be addressed by eating the
right Foods
ketogenic diet one that's heavy on fats
and light on carbohydrates helped
improve immune response and kept the
virus in check
at least in lab mice where the
researchers found a correlation between
diet and disease progression
[Music]
in the last 20 years both child and
maternal mortality rates have been
steadily falling
but one international study shows that
the global pandemic may have reversed
these gains
[Music]
lockdowns and curfews have been a
Hallmark of the covid-19 pandemic that
has stopped workers going to work it has
also kept people from urgently seeking
Health Care
scientists wanted to find out how
changes in the usage of healthcare
facilities likely impacted the number of
deaths of women due to childbirth and of
children under age five
the research took in data from more than
a hundred thousand Health Care Centers
in 18 low and lower middle income
countries so the authors found that in
these 18 countries uh on the whole the
use of healthcare services related to
maternal and child care declined and
they estimated that this has
repercussions on mortality so they're
estimating that child and maternal
mortality would have risen as a result
another Factor behind this rise is
economic hardship after job losses
caused by the pandemic not being able to
afford transport means not being able to
get to the hospital the nature of
maternal complications during childbirth
can be such that if you don't access
care within an hour or two window
you might die from it
babies and children can be similarly
vulnerable
the research published in plos medicine
estimated between March 2020 and June
2021 the number of children dying aged
under five could have risen by 3.6
percent
scientists say that such a loss of life
can be avoided if lessons are learned
from the covid-19 pandemic
in my mind I keep asking how is it
possible that people on the committee is
deciding about lockdowns forgot that
women give birth 24 hours seven and
there there are some sections of society
that really cannot wait even one hour to
get to a Essential Health Care
but some countries showed more positive
ways to deal with difficulty accessing
Health Care during the pandemic
nice examples was
one strict lockdown was put in place in
Uganda and hospitals were starting to
see the effects of this lockdown in both
ways the staff and the patients not
being able to get there on time they
communicated directly with the Ministry
of Health and with the national
authorities to gain exceptions and to
and to get information out there to
enable midwives nurses doctors as well
as pregnant and and and pregnant women
and sick children to be able to access
Care on time without delay good
communication can boost Health Care
attendance midwives could make use of
the fact that they have pregnant women's
contact details during pregnancy and
call them on the phone to explain any
necessary changes to care
changes at government level may also
help prevent excess deaths due to a lack
of Access to Health Care
a centralized approach from a health
agency to give the same guidelines to
the hospitals all at once about how to
deal with women in labor right from the
start of an outbreak would also
encourage trust and attendance
some positive outcomes from the pandemic
running water and hand washing
facilities and maternity Wards have
increased in number there is no one
quick fix to prevent a repeat of the
excess and preventable deaths during the
covid-19 pandemic but planning for the
next emergency should at least try
[Music]
it's the world's largest beer festival
and lasts over two weeks
organizers of this year's Oktoberfest
are expecting millions of visitors from
around the world and none of them will
be required to wear a mask
the risks of catching covid are high but
it's not putting anyone off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
these Munich residents aren't afraid of
covert they've known each other since
kindergarten and enjoy being together
during the Oktoberfest
joking talking and drinking friends
who've figured out life together from
exams and broken hearts to coronavirus
and lockdowns
is everyone here vaccinated we're all
vaccinated we're being careful it's fine
we just want to have fun
[Music]
just like everyone else here after a
two-year coronavirus break some 6
million people from around the world are
expected in Munich to celebrate the
world's most famous Festival
like this group
they've come all the way from California
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm happy that I'm back are you afraid
that this might be a surprise event no
no no no no no there's worse events
I feel like this is fine I feel safe I
don't feel weird I don't feel like I
have to put my mask on I feel okay I
hope it's not
[Applause]
regardless who you ask or where they're
from most people here feel the same the
risk is relatively low despite the
crowds
as long as they're tested vaccinated or
recovered people here feel safe
[Applause]
[Music]
we tested before we came out and we all
tested negative and we're here to have a
good time everyone already got the
corona we have a super uh super immune
doesn't matter
we have four of antibodies no care we
don't care
sure it's probably a super spreader
event you never know but are we supposed
to stay in don't we still want to go out
and celebrate
no I'm not afraid I am very happy with
it
yeah I enjoy a lot
[Music]
cheers
at the Oktoberfest some 2 in 100
randomly selected visen visitors tested
positive for covet 19.
so those planning to visit the reason
will have to accept a high risk of
infection
[Applause]
but the risk of catching covid-19 with
serious complications is very low
according to freedom and Gephardt from
the Technical University of Munich
he is already looking forward to
visiting the visan
I'm going to the Oktoberfest and I'm not
worried at all for three reasons the
Omicron variant is a virus that rarely
causes serious illness and on the other
hand we have a population that's mostly
been vaccinated at the same time a large
part of the population has already had
contact with the virus so there's a lot
of immunity out there already for those
who don't have any risk of serious
infection they can go to the reason and
not worry
that includes the more than 13 000
people keeping the festival running
[Applause]
people like Stephanie spendler
she's making a traditional dish called
kaiserchmann how worried is she about
catching covert 19.
somewhere in the middle I hope we all
stay healthy and we don't lose any
business and that everything runs well
until October 4th October
whether inside or outside nobody is
wearing a mask
covert tests are recommended but they're
not mandatory
it's also been recommended that people
who belong to various high-risk groups
get a booster
but some people have their own take
positive always have a positive attitude
that's the most important thing don't
worry about the flu or coronavirus it's
impossible to eradicate just look ahead
and drink a nice glass of beer and some
liquor too there's pure nature in it
you can't tell if someone is sick just
by looking at them doctors are expecting
higher infection rates but without the
serious consequences that clog up
hospital beds
at least that's how it was at other
festivals like the ones in the Bavarian
towns of rosenheim and staubing
let's hope it's the same at this year's
Oktoberfest
[Music]
do you have any questions about covid-19
our science correspondent Derek Williams
is here to answer them
just send your questions to
covidproducer gw.com
this week he answers the question
what does the latest data say about how
many asymptomatic cases there are
this question was a real conundrum
earlier in the pandemic and a lot of
scientists spent a lot of time trying to
figure out percentages of asymptomatic
cases back during 2020 and also during
the Alpha and the Delta days
the estimates they came up with varied
pretty widely but some of the most
convincing studies hypothesized that
somewhere around a third of all people
who tested positive for the disease
developed either very mild symptoms or
none at all
asymptomatic patients were an
interesting path of research to pursue
back then because most of us were still
on the same page in immunological terms
we hadn't been exposed and and learning
why some people didn't manifest any
symptoms after exposure it was thought
could Spur new treatments and therapies
but there's a big difference between
then and now the world has moved on we
now have going on two years of
vaccination programs and almost a year
of Omicron wave behind us over 12 and a
half billion doses of vaccines have been
given and over
600 million cases of the disease have
been confirmed with a whole lot more
unconfirmed
in many places on the planet Health Care
authorities say most of the population
has now been exposed we're still I think
a long way away from any declarations
that the coronavirus can be considered
endemic rather than pandemic but experts
now say that broader immunity due to
repeated encounters with the disease and
immune protection from vaccines that
they've helped lower the number of
deaths and people with serious disease
from highs last winter and although it's
almost impossible to nail down really
firm data at this point a lot of doctors
believe that those factors have also
pretty dramatically increased the number
of asymptomatic cases out there in other
words
after recovering from the disease when
people get it again experts think
they'll in general be somewhat less
likely to develop noticeable symptoms
especially if they've been vaccinated as
well the problem is
the Omicron variant is incredibly
infectious so asymptomatic people can
still transmit the disease even if they
don't notice having it themselves
studies now indicate that in the current
covid paradigm
asymptomatic people are seeding half or
even more of all new cases so
even if plenty of people are now shaking
off infection quickly they're still
often passing it on to others which will
continue to prolong the pandemic in the
near future
[Music]
donated blood is essential for patients
whose lives depend on blood transfusions
but it can only be stored for up to 42
days
and artificial blood continues to be
hard to make
in many parts of the world there's now a
serious blood supply shortage and the
East African country of Uganda is
particularly hard hit
[Music]
Ugandan hospitals are experiencing an
unprecedented blood shortage
many patients are Waiting in Vain for
urgently needed transfusions
see patients with acute leukemia
I see patients who have been bleeding
and you need a particular product and
you can't get it
it is heartbreaking
you have patience a child
who dies because they are anemic
it's not a good experience
at the national Blood Bank Authorities
blame the blood scarcity on the covid-19
lockdowns
everyone is a responsibility
Uganda had a blood shortfall before the
pandemic
the ones
the shortage was worsened when schools
and universities had to close for almost
two years
17 is the minimum age for blood donors
Ugandan students make up over 85 percent
of voluntary donors donating blood at
centralized School clubs and medical
camps at universities
with these closed during lockdowns
mobilizing the public to donate blood
became a challenge
[Applause]
you could hardly meet our
tag it and we advise the hospitals
preserve only blood for emergencies only
and leave the operations so the patients
that needed the operations had to wait
lockdowns extended to public transport
which added to the problem
kagosi says that he had to use his
special privileges as a senior
government official to enter a donation
center
[Applause]
because even if you you are uncovered or
locked down that doesn't stop people
from getting sick or mother is
delivering but where do they get it if
everybody cannot move so for us a few of
us who could move then we had the option
of moving to hit this place donate the
little we can while we mobilize those
others who could do the same during the
same time it was a little tricky
but with hospitals struggling to catch
up with medical procedures that had been
postponed during the pandemic blood
remains scarce even now that lockdowns
have been lifted
with less than 450 000 units of safe
blood collected annually
Uganda is below the World Health
Organization recommendation which
requires at least one percent of a
country's population to donate blood
yesterday
you study but one
we came today in around the trail of we
reached there and he told us to wait for
two to three hours
sad to be here and wait for the blood
you come expecting you may be on all
three of but you reach here when you
almost started this that hospital Zone
in the blood
and those in the lab have to minimize
and see that each of you have actually
can have what to take away
to those people
according to the who the panda led to a
30 drop in blood supply globally
[Applause]
blood banks are trying to encourage more
people to become donors
and also appealing to people who already
do so to give more blood even more
frequently
[Music]
we'll be back next week with another my
covid story Justice Lee adeboya from
Ghana tells us how doctors wrongly
diagnosed him with typhus back in
February 2021
after they finally diagnosed him with
covid-19 it took him another month to
recover
fortunately he's not suffered any
long-term health problems
see you next week and until then goodbye
and stay healthy
[Music]